Hi everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
It's several questions coming in, so I'll start with those, but I'm
ready to chat in your questions if you have other questions.
Also, I'm ready to look at any updates and announcements on the
member site and you can self-schedule calls on that site.
We'll just go to our website and you can self-schedule.
Okay, first question that came in.
Naglease blood tests are advertised as a way to track cancer.
Is this test something you could use to track cancer reoccurrence?
What are the pros and cons of reoccurrence testing?
Some clinics use it, but also read research that can't be reproduced.
Any thoughts on this?
Well, there's pros and cons to every test.
So there's different Naglease tests that are out there.
There's the reds Naglease test that you could run with different
clinics and that is sent over to Europe to run it.
None, there are any Naglease tests done in the United States.
Oh, that is sent over to Europe for that test.
We have never, I don't know, not about it because I don't run that test.
I, when we were looking into it, I saw too many inconsistency.
So we didn't, we just didn't, I just didn't get into it.
I just didn't feel good about it for many reasons.
I can't remember all of them.
There was a person that I know well that uses it.
Another practitioner and she really thinks the best of it.
But she is not a light and licensed in any way.
So she has the ability to run any other blood work.
That was kind of her go-to thing.
You know, I don't think it is, but I don't think it's very accurate.
Then there's that test that you can send over to the nila.
That's a different test similar to the Naglease test.
But then they're in COVID, that became extinct because they weren't accepting any more new tests
because they were inundated with testing.
I don't know.
Somebody asked a question about that test.
A month or so ago, and they were going to check and see if they're accepting any new tests.
Now, I do think that test, though it seemed even more hoki-poki,
was actually more accurate.
And that was simply by a making that assumption based upon experience,
that based on any research, because I don't think there's any research on that test.
That's a urine test.
I don't know if that is up and running.
Again, you do that test in your whole.
That's the Navarro HCG test.
But I don't know if that what is up and running again.
Now, that would give you a reading of 0 to 180 over 50 is positive for cancer.
It doesn't tell you what type of cancer.
And it's a, it's kind of like a tumor marker test.
And it's just every years throughout all the 25 years of dealing with cancer patients,
that test was like correct everybody that did it.
So I was, I was impressed with that test.
And when people were getting better via their symptoms via evidence on CT scans and pet scans,
and they would run that Navarro test, the number would come down.
And you didn't give any data on yourself.
So there wasn't any bias or anything.
So it was so, it was just it ran perfectly with other testing.
So I was very impressed with that test.
The positive moment was that you had to send it over to the Philippines to get red.
And it, so it took like two to two to four weeks to get your results back.
The positive was so inexpensive.
I think it was like 55 bucks.
I don't know what it is now.
Again, I don't know if it's up and running again.
So somebody wants to check into the Navarro test.
You know, they test again, I'm not against them.
And it can be another marker.
And, but like any test you measure it, you know, on a graph.
But you measure from, you know, over time.
And you can see the changes over time.
But it may be accurate.
I just, we haven't run enough of them to really know.
And I haven't had enough people do it to really make it a proper assessment,
whether I think it was, it was good or not.
But I think adding any, any testing that is, that is semi non-pin basic can be another good way to make measurements.
Next question.
My IDC is dairy.
But the bundwig diet of cottage cheese and flax oil is recommended.
Do you suggest I stay away from that entirely or maybe do it once in a while?
So, dairy is a driver of your cancer.
If you talk to the people from bundwig, they'll say that adding flax oil to the cottage cheese and blending it up changes the dairy.
And it no longer drives cancer.
But there, from a physiological standpoint, that makes no sense.
You could cook dairy in a pasta.
You could make dairy into cheese.
You could make dairy into, you know, whatever you want.
It's still going to have the same physiological effect on your body.
It's, that's not going to change the dairy so that it won't be a gross driver.
The most dairy is a growth driver or I should say dairy is a growth driver for most people's cancer.
So, if a person says, okay, well, I know dairy is a driver, but I do want to do bundwig.
And they're staying away from all other dairy, but they're doing bundwig.
That's it.
That's just a call that you have to make.
I mean, if you're really going to stay away from all dairy, you can't do bundwig.
But if you're going to make that call with your, let's say, your cancer is in a state where it's growing and I've been dairy free for a period of time.
And now it's growing and I want to try the bundwig protocol.
Then I don't have any trouble with trying the bundwig protocol.
Now, if you're at a state where there isn't, there's very little growth and you're doing well, and you're off dairy, I would be very hesitant to try the bundwig protocol.
I just got off the phone with somebody yesterday who was doing very, very well with their cancer.
And for some reason, they got off of their diet because their husband was doing a carnivore type diet, but it was doing a carnivore type diet with dairy.
And he was eating a punch of dairy with meat.
And she started on that diet with him and she had a big flare.
But I think it was more a flare of dairy sensitivity issue because you have it all sorts of weird symptoms.
And I don't think we're tied to her cancer, but it can make a change that fast.
So it really depends on where the person's at with their cancer.
So if your cancer is barely stable at the moment and you're dairy free, I wouldn't go jump into the bundwig diet.
If your cancer was growing and you've been dairy free and you've been doing a lot of things and you want to give bundwig a shot that I would say go forward, give bundwig a shot.
That's up to you.
But you but I would not I do not believe what what the bundwig people say is that if you had a black seed to the to the cottage cheese that changes the physiological characteristics of dairy, well, there's no evidence of that.
I don't believe that, but I don't see a problem with somebody trying it.
My oncologist responded the nurse phone about the five-year risk of reoccurrence for my risk profile doing chemotherapy or just watching weight observation.
That's your where he got his cystic but here they are.
If I do chemotherapy, I have a 20 in 100 chance of reoccurrence in five years.
If I do watch and wait, I have a 30 to 40 in 100 chance of reoccurrence in five years.
So the success rate is as 80% with chemotherapy versus 60 to 70% with no chemotherapy.
Not sure how significant that is in the grand scheme of things, thoughts and perspective on those stats.
Yeah, to be honest, I do not know where these oncologists get their statistics, because I like I said last week I just cannot believe that they're logging people into some database, especially people that are opted out of their care.
It's just I just don't know that that is true.
Now, there may be a study out there that was done under 300 people and they watched them over five years.
There was a percentage that watched and wait versus the percentage that did chemotherapy.
And if it was a properly conducted study that would be interested interested to look at the problem is with the people that watched and wait.
I mean, what's the percentage of if these statistics were correct based upon whatever data, you're you're still so it's still so skewed because
we're the people that watched and wait a category of elderly people that did not want to do chemotherapy because they were too old and too feeble.
And you got to think that that was a person that was probably a large percentage of those people.
Number two, were they people that that did have insurance and didn't do other things that you know would be good for their health, they weren't doing any other alternative things.
What percentage of those people that watch and wait waited in this statistic pool were doing alternative stages as well.
I mean, there's a lot of there's a lot of things that can skew this data.
So like any statistics one can make them say whatever they want to say.
So while it's good to have some frame of reference that they're giving you, it's not giving you enough frame of reference that makes you go, wow, I better do this or that.
Back to always not enough difference there based upon all sorts of variables that could have been that in those categories that would make me want to go and do chemotherapy.
Oh, it would make me want to do chemotherapy would be we have statistical data that 90% of the people that do chemotherapy do not have recurrence in five years.
And you know, and 90% of the people who don't do chemotherapy do every occurance in five years, well then I scratch my head and go boy, I need to really think about that.
So, you know, it's, you know, with my cancer, it was really easy to make a decision not to because it was well, we have this wonderful new study from mail that showed that doing cable therapy, we had two of 10 people live 15 months.
Okay, well, that is so bad that why would anybody want to do that?
You know, they just don't think there's any other options and they were bragging about it.
So, you know, you're back to, you know, well, I got a 10 or 20% improvement doing chemotherapy by their statistics.
But what's the, what's the skewer ratio on that statistical data? I think it's greater than 10 to 20%.
So, you have to believe that the people in the, there's a good percentage of the people in the watching wave group that are that did that there's a lot of the majority of people who choose not to do chemotherapy are that elderly.
That just think that are true feeble that they think that they that the chemo will kill them.
The majority of younger people developing cancer are choosing to go the oncology route.
You know, you know, I will say the majority of people that come to us are, you know, over 50 over 60 that are really seeking our care.
We're not getting that you could say, well, you're not getting there's the people in the 20s don't have cancer.
Well, that's not necessarily true.
And certainly not after the COVID vaccines, there's more and more people getting cancer.
So, you know, I don't know that a 10 to 20% statistical improvement doing chemo based upon their statistics surpasses the error rate of these statistics for me.
But again, you don't look just at the statistics, you look at, you know, you're, you're, you're comparing a lot of things and what is, you know, hopefully, you're, you're praying about this and you're asking God for, you know, direction in your care.
And I know you are, and you know, you just try to follow that as best you can.
And yes, you couple it with trying to gain knowledge, you try to gain as much wisdom as possible.
And if you're asking my opinion, I don't know that this 10 to 20% improvement by doing chemo surpasses the error rate in the statistic, the statistical data here.
So, to be with this would not be convincing me to do chemo therapy.
Okay, that's all the questions that we have sent in. So, if you have any other questions, I did look up the Navarro test and their website still says due to a supply chain issue.
They are unable to form any HCG urine tests for cancer.
Very COVID, I remember I think they were, they were really bogged down, but I did hear through the grapevine that the government was came after them too.
So, I think that was an issue as well. So, I don't know the whole story behind their ability to do testing.
So, thank you for that link, for the NAGELACE blood test. I don't know if everybody can see that link if you want to go to that.
There's a whole bunch of information, particularly alternative perspectives written about NAGELACE.
To me, it's another form of a, like a tumor marker test.
So, you know, anything you can do again that is less invasive is to be beneficial.
So, is there a test that just tells you about your bad estrogen? I read there's an estrogen methylation urine test.
I was just wondering if there was a less expensive way to keep tracking that number than doing an entire Dutch test.
The Dutch test does test your methylated estrogen, your methylated estrogen E1 as well.
I don't know. I don't know if there is a way just to test the 16 hydroxyesteroid.
I don't know that I know doctors data has a Dutch panel too, but I think it's around the same price.
I don't think it's really any cheaper, but really you probably only need to run that test about at once every six months or so.
So, I know $300 every six months is still $300, but I don't know that there's another test out that just measures the 16 hydroxy.
And I don't know that that's really smart to do because you do want to look at, you know, your levels of progesterone testosterone as well, because you're going to have a robotization going on.
So, I think it's valuable to measure that as well.
Any other questions?
No, always.
Same thing. Just saying thank you.
Oh, you're welcome. I shared everything.
No, I hope that I gave you a vague answer, but I hope it helps you.
No, it's, I mean, it's like where these guys come up with this stuff.
I mean, there's no probabilities information with it.
The good part is my insurance allows me to have a second opinion.
All these same questions to the Cleveland Clinic.
They do, they allow me to do it for free. So, I'll see what happens. There are two.
Yeah.
I just really have a hard time believing that they're organized enough to be putting people in a database and following them over a period of time.
Especially, you got to think that at least half the people that don't choose to do chemo.
Don't go back to that doctor.
And, you know, may not, you know, especially if they're doing well, may not go back, you know, to be calculated in a five year data study.
So, they're certainly not the nurses are sitting there, you know, googling obituaries on people, you know, I just where they coming up with that stuff.
I just, I mean, I'm not saying that they're pulling it out of their hat.
I'm just saying, I don't know where they're, I don't know where they're getting that data.
If they, if that data was public data, because they showed, you know, the numbers at each category, then you, it makes it more believable.
But if, you know, you just Google it, you say you got this percent chance, who said that?
I can't believe anything on Google anymore.
So, I just, it's not even on that. So, I mean, it's, it's just, I just question it.
That's all I do. It is just saying. I just, that's why I personally, I have people that call me and say, what's your successor?
We don't give a success, right? What are, how do you measure that?
What do you, how do you measure success? A person that's still alive, 30 years later, 20 years later, 10 years later.
What, we're all going to die. So, I mean, what's success? You know, it's, it's difficult.
You know, well, the oncologists are, you know, great at throwing numbers out and saying these things.
It's just they don't have any negative recourse to not telling the truth.
Whereas, you know, if I gave out some statistical data,
first of all, it would be dishonest. Secondly, it would be, it would probably come back and haunt me, you know, from a medical legal standpoint.
They just don't have it. They could say anything they want and do anything they want.
So, yeah, it's, it's difficult. It's some, you know, I think it's good to ask.
And maybe it's good to say where do you get that data, you know, but I don't know if you'll get a straight answer.
I wish I could be more helpful. All right. Any more questions? Sir, we'll call it a night.
All right. Thanks, everybody. And I'll be praying for your decision. And hopefully, you know, just get really peace about whatever, just whatever you decide.
Thank you. Thank you. All right. Bye-bye, everybody.